hi I'm Chris Arvin a designer mo ba de
and they work on the Expedia the Expedia
bliss uses book travel and helps them
along their travel since the Android
design guide was published we've
completely redesigned the Expedia app
and held great Android design as a
priority going forward and to do that we
knew we had to go beyond the design
guide and do a few things really well
these included making delightful
interaction for the user using pure
Android visuals that also fit our apps
brand and making sure that things that
are important to the user are available
quickly so when user opens our app
they're presented with a scrolling list
of hotels and flight destinations we use
full bleed imagery and magazine style
layout they see in apps like the people
out for example and a lot of our users
come to our app to book hotels on the
same night in their current location so
we make those available immediately and
on that same note if user has booked
travel with us before and their travels
in progress we automatically take them
to their trips we show them everything
upcoming that they've booked in this
card based google now style timeline
instead of being hidden under a drawer
menu the details that user leave for
their travel is available immediately
and we love adding little touches to our
out they give it personality and emotion
for example when a user's waiting for
their flyer results to load we give them
this plane window they can play around
with by tilting the phone or moving the
window shade and when the flyer is also
ready we show them on top of this large
beautiful photo of their destination to
lighten up the data heavy nature of fly
ourselves and get them excited about
their potential trip and when users
ready to check out
we give them the rewarding interaction
of sliding to purchase
and it's that simple we try to make the
entire screen feel like you're still in
android whether it be from the flat
visuals or the icons we use and then we
have to take it one more step and give
these niceties like how a user can pull
down the photo gallery to start seeing
the entire photo or how they can scroll
into the sort of parallax or the map in
the background and I think it hold
touches like that that make the user
appreciate you on a deeper level and
we've really found is that our users
respond positively to the attention we
pay to design in the smallest ways in
large weight as well over the past year
our app has grown from 300,000 active
installs to over two million active
installs and we found that making me
carefully design entered up really
matters